bom pessoal é gostaria de começar a tal
que hoje é fazendo uma pergunta pra
vocês que é um quando foi o momento que
você se deu conta de que você de fato é
um ser humano vai trazer agora na sua
cabeça não somente esse momento exato
que você se deparou com esse fato que
você constatou que você é realmente um
ser humano parece ser um pouco difícil
na verdade a gente apontar com precisão
esse momento na nossa vida não é que
olha sou um ser humano parece que na
verdade sempre soube disso na verdade
quer mais em espanha
vamos tentar na verdade fazer um pouco
mais pro agora nem pensar é qual é o
elemento qual é o atributo que permite
ainda agora até hoje você de fato
acreditar que é um ser humano é quem já
assistiu aquele curta documentário do
jorge furtado vai lembrar que nenhum
argumento muito interessante para falar
sobre isso que é a que responde o ser
humano se diferenciar possuirá encéfalo
altamente desenvolvido e polegares
opositores otan encéfalo altamente
desenvolvido permite ao ser humano é
capturar e armazenar informações né
processá-los relacionadas entendê los e
isso somado a capacidade motora dos
polegares opositores permitem o ser
humano trial não sem número de melhorias
no mundo
acho interessante na verdade esse
argumento do furtado é que por trás dele
existe um argumento ainda maior que na
ciência se convencionou chamar de
humanismo o humanismo minas gerais
defende que a única maneira de se
capturar os e na condição humana é
através dessa capacidade sui generis que
a gente tem de produzir pensamento e de
produzir é coisa de criar coisas não
importa tanto
gente bem de fato o momento exato em que
a gente se reconheceu como ser humano
o que importa é saber que somos seres
humanos e que é a partir dessa
constatação que a gente é capaz de
questionar a natureza da nossa realidade
bom eu pergunto você já questionou a
natureza da sua realidade
o interessante é essa pergunta é porque
humanista diria por exemplo que somente
a realidade só pode ser acessada de fato
por pessoas e entidades capazes de
pensar capazes de criar mas será que
isso realmente é verdade nem vamos por
exemplo olhar o caso de honra nesse
vermelho me é um pintor dessa obra
clássica na moça com brinco de pérola é
é um entorno holandês considerado um dos
grandes pintores de realismo na
humanidade
e aí tem e vermelha tinha possuía de
fato então encerro altamente
desenvolvido e polegares opositores
querem sexo novamente desenvolvido de
vermelho tinha ele pensará melhor
combinação cromática possível pra com a
harmonia de suas obras né e o polegar
opositor me tinha vermelho o movimento
de pinça e a partir disso uma
manipulação com precisão de instrumentos
de pintura que para acabar de fato de
suas obras mas tem um elemento muito
interessante essa história que é a
questão de como alguns alguns sugerem
que em vermelho usava já naquela época
um instrumento conhecido a linha por
volta de 1600 no século 17 um
instrumento chamado câmara escura para a
câmera escura como escolher um
dispositivo alimentar é precursor do que
alguns anos mais tarde viria a ser
chamada de câmera fotográfica não era
capaz de pegar
a imagem uma cena real e projetar essa
essa cena numa superfície e sugerem sion
que vai me utilizar essa técnica para
atingiu galdi realismo de fato que ele
tinha nas suas obras
o interessante na verdade desse ponto
intrigante é perceber que somente o
unicef novamente desenvolvido de
vermelho e polegares opositores por si
só não eram muito capazes de produzir a
realidade de reproduzir com perfeição a
realidade
se isso for verdade mesmo ver-me
precisou de muitas mediações técnicas
para atingir esse grau de perfeição de
realismo
esse é meu ponto nós sempre precisamos
de muita mediação técnica para acessar a
realidade
por exemplo existe um sociólogo francês
gilberto e simulou que ele afirma que a
maior causa de alienação no interior da
vida se há algum tempo por ano
é o fábio de ignorarmos a essência da
máquina né e por conta disso a
conseqüente a ausência da máquina no
quadro de valores que formam a cultura é
para simon a assim como existe uma
filogenia que explica a evolução dos
seres humanos
existe também uma filogenia que explica
a evolução das máquinas a evolução na
clínica em que faz bastante sentido na
verdade
veja o corpo humano evoluiu ao longo dos
anos ao longo do tempo até chegar a esse
padrão sabe
e da mesma maneira a gente consegue
analisar a evolução de automação das
máquinas a evolução de forma das
máquinas o que nos prova que na verdade
nós estamos sempre uma relação de
coexistência numa relação de troca é uma
relação de troca que nós podemos chamar
de mediações técnicas ou de interface
humano máquina vamos pensar um pouquinho
mais no tempo para a gente poder pensar
sobre isso né a gente poder pensar na
verdade voltando naquela questão que
quais são os elementos
diferenciariam do mundo né ao redor que
ser que seja exatamente a criatividade
eo pensamento né porque parece que é o
pensamento humano existe algum algo de
muito de privilégio no ser humano que se
coloca acima de todas as relações
me parece que existe algo de especial
conforme sugere a o ideal humanismo de
que o ser humano deve de fato se colocá
lo o de todas as relações ea partir
disso justificar do tipo de incursão no
mundo todo tipo de incursão de melhorias
enfim amparar s que realmente é e se é
aquilo uma ideia que realmente nos
governa até hoje nenhum eu tive um
professor do mestrado professor pimenta
professor mandantes e uma coisa muito
interessante sobre isso que a última
questão com a qual nós vamos precisar
romper é exatamente com o sentido da
subjetividade humana ou seja nós vamos a
entender que existem outras entidades ao
nosso redor circulando no mundo com a
gente e que elas não são portanto meros
recursos para a expansão do nosso
bem-estar - nosso desejo e aí voltando
no tempo então eu gosto muito dessa
imagem é é apaixonado por essa cena na
verdade pra quem já assistiu 2001 uma
odisséia no espaço
provavelmente vai lembrar essa cena e
pra mim é icônica emblemática porque ela
mostra um momento que surge no mundo
duas entidades distintas e
complementares entre si que é o ser
humano ea máquina bom
muitas pessoas poderiam na verdade me
dizer mas isso é uma máquina é isso aí
eu objeto uma ferramenta algo é nesse
sentido é tipo a máquinas
a gente tem essa noção é que máquinas
são inventadas só depois da revolução de
drogas não é tão verdade assim nós temos
na verdade é uma relação humana
mark acontecendo desde sempre é pensar
no ser humano separado das relações com
o mundo ao redor
desde o plano é natural até o plano
artificial é é um imprudente quanto
lançam cosmonauta no no espaço sideral
então vejam e fica interessante falar
isso porque nós começamos a perceber que
as máquinas elas criam elas são tão
capazes de criar o mundo quando nós
somos capazes de criar um mundo porque
nós estamos em relação desde sempre
eu gosto muito de usar o termo maquilon
coesi pra identificar exatamente essa
condição de criação da máquina
poiésis aí sendo na verdade o termo
grego para a criação porque é
interessante pensar na máquina o conhece
porque hoje em dia sobretudo é muito
mais simples muito mais fácil pra gente
acreditar e aceitar o fato de que as
máquinas criam por exemplo seu celular
pega seu celular e agora provavelmente
vai com ele no seu bolso na sua mão
vamos supor que você vai sair hoje aqui
do evento você vai abrir seu celular vai
pedir para o seu google maps que
indicará a melhor rota possível até a
sua casa para sua residência quando esse
resultado aparecendo apela você seria
capaz de me responder quem foi que criou
e aí a gente poderia dizer que foi o
algoritmo de busca
a gente poderia dizer que foi na verdade
o hardware do seu celular que o
responsável por gerar esse resultado
poderia também mas também gente poderia
dizer que só foi possível por conta de
toda a estrutura de call cloud computing
do google né
ou melhor ainda a gente poderia dizer na
verdade que só foi possível por conta
dos satélites que orbitam a pé ou ainda
que na verdade só conseguiu interagir
porque o seu sistema operacional tem uma
interface amigável algo do tipo o que se
mostra pouca gente na verdade que não
tem como a gente aponta hoje em dia
o mais difícil pra gente a uma causa
raiz num lugar o único onde essas coisas
saem acontece e sobretudo que não existe
mais um domínio humano apenas nesse
processo de criação
nós vamos falando de uma complexidade de
fatores né de dispositivos que dialogam
em inglês e em bonn pensa na verdade a
examine seu celular e pensa em todas as
questões que seu celular pode é capaz de
criar nem como que ele mostra na verdade
o mundo complexo no qual a gente vive de
como é de fato complexo organizar esse
mundo é um exemplo outro exemplo recente
interessante sobre essa questão é no
começo durante testes de carros
autônomos naouri ocorreu um acidente que
que acabou gerando a morte o óbito de
uma mulher e vamos aos fatos
o carro onu estava em alta velocidade
acima da permitida gera bastante bizarro
existia no momento do acidente um ser
humano motorista ser humano dentro do
carro ea mulher por sua vez atravessava
fora da faixa e aí eu deixo a pergunta
pra vocês
de quem foi a culpa é tão difícil quanto
aquela primeira pergunta é apontar de
fato nenhuma causa raiz uma culpa é
específica porque na verdade a culpa ela
vai distribuindo nessa rede de relações
não dá mais para a gente analisar pelo
por uma liminar idade a e b é tentar
apontar assim é algum tipo de de
precisão um tipo de raiz para pôr os
problemas de enchente na verdade está
percebendo que essa raiz é muito mais
complexa e se arranja amento de que as
coisas muito mais complexo ea máquina
tem de fato um papel preponderante na
determinação dessas de como a gente vai
viver a nossa vida de forma a gente vai
passar daqui pra frente
a viver em sociedade
a gente pode por exemplo começar a falar
de serviços nem serviços como por
exemplo da startup brasileira anos kim
que produz na verdade rejuvenescimento
através de biobío zaine você já parou
pra imaginar a em viver em um mundo onde
você pode escolher o coletor você quer
envelhecer
isso pode impactar bastante a vida
humana pode é a gente pode falar por
exemplo de assistentes virtuais né a
gente pode falar que vou modificar a
maneira como a gente se organiza para
viver a vida no dia a dia a gente pode
falar de como a rotina como a questão da
internet das coisas espalhavam pelo ao
nosso redor pode mudar o comportamento
social com o passar do tempo nessa gente
se a gente for falar que só do mercado
de inteligências artificiais
a gente está falando de uma projeção é
de uma produção de riquezas de 36
bilhões de dólares até 2020 que daqui a
dois anos
na américa do sul por exemplo estamos
falando de aumento de um ponto
percentual no pib dos países até 2035
vejam o tamanho desses mercados com os
quais nós estamos lidando agora
e vejam que esses mercados a maior parte
deles não existiam há 15 20 anos atrás
então o que nos mostra na verdade é que
todo o nosso potencial social econômico
cultural sendo modificado pela presença
é direta das máquinas dessas máquinas
inteligentes na nossa vida não pensa por
exemplo a no tamanho do impacto é que
isso pode causar
na área de serviços né na área de
indústria da inteligência pensa em tudo
aquilo que o ser humano faz que é capaz
ível de ser automatizado ou mecanizado
esse é o tamanho do impacto que nós
vamos ter com essa nova era das máquinas
digitais nas máquinas criativas né
o mei isso sei lá por exemplo no assunto
desse organismo é o mercados emergentes
que produzem dispositivos que acoplados
aos por romano melhoram o corpo humano
é vejam isso não se tratava mais de 1
uma previsão do futuro uma pendência
daquilo que a gente pode vir a viver ou
não isso já é realidade
esse é o zeitgeist na verdade que funda
os nossos tempos
a tecnocracia é esse site pois nós
estamos vivendo cada vez mais num mundo
regido pela tecnologia
nós vamos precisar nos equipe próprio é
que para levar dentro dessa nova
complexidade que se apresenta para a
gente
por exemplo recentemente também o
presidente da frança emmanuel macron se
posicionou publicamente sobre uma
estratégia para o mercado de
inteligência artificiais na frança
nessa uma mera uma entrevista com ele na
wired e eu li e achei interessante mas o
que mais me intrigou na verdade foi a
maneira como uma cruz se posiciona com
relação aos problemas éticos que vão
dividir essa nova era de máquinas
inteligentes dizendo que a europa ea
frança seriam lugares mais indicados
para pensar esses dilemas éticos
justificando que eles são pioneiros na
questão é democrática no que diz
respeito à democracia e na verdade eu
estou até hoje tentando entender se isso
foi um devaneio uma hipocrisia da parte
de micro porque pensar que a europa é
privilegiada de alguma maneira para
pensar esses dilemas é no mínimo
ignorância histórica nem jogar para fora
todo o contexto de escravizá são de
outros povos de colonização de outros
países
mede até genocídio como o nazismo não
assim não acho que isso de fato
qualifique a europa a frança para falar
de ética melhor do que outras pessoas ou
mesmo se a gente quiser lá no debate
democrático do democracia é questionar é
que o doping é essa a gente está
escolhendo acreditar que justifica que
de fato a gente vive num mundo onde
exista algum processo democrático
néné é uma ilusão acreditar eu acho
vejam a recente desmonte consciência
nível público no brasil
nem de longe a maneira como isso foi
organizado se parece com o processo
democrático
é bom que a gente começa a perceber é
que o significado de conviver com essas
novas máquinas inteligentes é menos
sobre a interface é menos sobre a
facilidade que elas nos prazos a
comodidade que elas promove e muito mais
sobre se arranjar momento político que
existe por trás delas porque por trás
delas na maneira como ela chega pra
gente existem personalidades existem
poder existem na verdade o poder de
conduzir de indicar o rumo dessa
sociedade tecnocrata e a partir do
momento que isso muda o nosso modus
operanti isso exige da gente um novo
equipamento ético um novo equipamento
ético que inclua as máquinas nesse
processo
o bacana de estudo pessoal é que nós
somos tão protagonistas quanto às
máquinas na construção desse admirável
mundo novo
talvez as incluindo as máquinas e
aceitando essa nossa condição de co
existência a gente seja capaz de fato de
vencer e ultrapassar esse último rincão
que é o sentido da subjetividade humana
e talvez vencemos esse humanismo fajuta
que opera a nossa sociedade
obrigado